[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
hey what's up everybody what happy
Thursday hopefully you guys have had a
good week we are back I'm Eric we're
gonna do some dusty two again today cuz
this destiny two week I figure it's the
first you know a couple days you guys
might need some tips on farming what to
do after story how to be efficient so
let's go ahead and get into that I am
actually I think I can hit to actually
get it higher I'm gonna hit to six to
sixty seven is my like current max light
like if I was to go max max light so
yeah we'll see we'll see what what's up
with that and what we can do a couple of
things we're probably just gonna start
off with is I want to tell you guys if
you haven't done this you guys should do
it when you can buy these from Kade by
the Scout reports they basically show
you where treasure chests are roughly
and treasure chests are good because
they give you potentially these tokens
and every 20 tokens you turn in you can
get loot
I'm gonna show you a little run will
start off on necess because I was on
nessus a lot this morning and I figured
I'd show you guys this this little run
here this little farming run because
it's pretty straightforward and there's
kind of a lot of a there's kind of a lot
of chests actually if if there's not a
lot of people there opening other ones
and kind of ruining your cycle almost
reminds me of the rocket yard if you
guys did that back in the day on destiny
one but again just want to say thank you
guys all for tuning in
you know GameSpot is live every day at
11 a.m. we're probably gonna do more
destiny to tomorrow maybe we'll try some
trials of the nine or trials of Osiris
I think it's called trials of the nine
now we might get rekt but you know
there's probably good rewards there it's
worth trying also sir is gonna be back
tonight or this morning depending on how
you look at it
so we'll probably take a look at that as
well
tomorrow we'll probably also have
something up to night showing that if
you guys are curious I'm also using the
an exotic hand cannon called Sturm right
now I'm gonna have a guide on how to get
that later today as well so let's make
sure do I have the necesitas II so what
you want to do like I said if you guys
have it is you want to pop the Scout
report for a planet you think you're
gonna be on for awhile this costs about
five thousand glimmer I think it's
totally worth it because you'll see
hopefully hopefully this doesn't making
a liar but we can kind of go in a circle
and essentially we can farm chests so
there's one right there already and like
I said there's chests we'll give you a
lethal token I've gotten a legendary
Engram out of one
so there you go blue Nessa's token every
ten is like 50% rep every twenty is like
100 here's another chest and the other
good thing about this area this is flat
right yes Exodus black this area is he's
right here I think I was gonna say
there's a heroic or a pup sorry there's
a public event that's nearby that's one
that's one good thing it's like right
over there so every like you know 10 to
15 minutes you can do a public event
also there's a high-value target that's
like right around the corner here too
and you can kill him and get a coin as
well and then you can also if you've
unlocked patrols you can also do patrols
at the same time you get a coin from
that you also want to pick up those I
forget what it's the data forget what
it's called
exactly but you want to pick those up
too and so I will pick a patrol here I
pick up patrol I only do sure and pick
up the floor with another chest right
there so that's three chests already so
in the span of like five minutes we've
gotten well hopefully a third point
sometimes we don't get a coin so that's
three coins
it's not trigger than heroic event to
her opening another event
so you can go over here you know start
rally the flag essentially
and in three minutes we'll have an event
to do good also show you guys about
heroic public events if you guys don't
know about that
oh thanks 0hx see saying cool here shirt
you got the reference I haven't watched
it here in a long time but good movie so
what's up Shrek Tex here's another chess
board chess so nessus this first area is
like pretty good see that time we didn't
get a coin so sometimes you're gonna not
get a coin which is not the end of the
world obviously it does suck a little
bit but usually the good thing too is if
you're the one opening a lot of these
chests you're gonna kind of have like a
good chance at opening the other ones
there's not other people kind of like
opening the test and I think someone
asked me what my what's my favorite
o'clock so far I still think it's
graviton Lance
the hand cannon tank cannon I'm using is
called Sturm and it's really interesting
because I want to say it's the first
time in Destiny that they've had
something like this it's a combo package
so this secondary sidearm I have is
called ring let me show you that and
basically they work together so
everytime I get a kill with Sturm it
reloads my drain and everytime I get a
kill with Drang it reloads my Sturm so
basically you don't have to ever reload
now I'm not big on hand cannons side
outside of fate bring but can you talk
to people near you now or still no call
I don't know if that has ever been in
the game where you could just talk to
random people I think you have to be in
like a
it could be wrong I've never done that
though so there it reloaded my Sturm
vice versa if I killed someone with this
crap nope someone over the chest must
get to chest they get it I guess I did
you didn't get a coin outta here it
sucks obviously that's fine it happens
this is destiny to Joe Smith you should
read the manga for a curated round of
the story okay how long is it zero is it
like really long so yeah this is
basically the farming route
here's another chest
[Applause]
you know we haven't been picking up the
Oh Evan cones right and we were getting
unlucky on the coins you started off so
hot there was one time I did have like
30 coins and I feel like it's slowed
down a bit in terms of being drops but I
think I only have like eight yeah I'm
just getting the lucky but you saw what
you see the potential I hope you just
basically toggle the weapons back and
forth all right we got our public event
also got that's that other data lattice
we'll see which one we got try to
trigger the heroic for you guys if you
guys didn't know there's a way to
trigger her oh but that's we're also
gonna have a video on
that'll explain how to do a bunch of
them
it'll hopefully explain how to do on
this one's a bit tricky
hopefully my teammates know what to do
because we pretty much have to kill that
servitor like ASAP the babies over here
so this guy this guy knows so basically
this boss has multiple servitors that
will come out and protect it so in order
to trigger the hero you have to make
sure you kill every one of those
servitors it does get a little hairy and
tricky later on because he's gonna
summon three at one time and they don't
stay for very long so hopefully when he
spawned some more we can get rid of them
prior to save me
okay all right we triggered the hero
which is awesome obviously
so now
kind of hard to do these heroic events
now the reason why you want to do the
heroics
because you have a higher chance or a
better chance of more loops or better
loop
people have confirmed that your pan gets
out of this
I haven't never got one so unfortunately
nothing crazy there but if you can you
want to try to do the heroics if
possible I have gotten like four loot
from heroic before though so showing you
guys that all right we finally got
soaking out of a test which is good
rage Alucard says service german it
means storm like charge attack Drang is
German word for urge
[Applause]
so yeah for me primarily I just did a
lot of I soloed most of my leveling
fortunately because I started earlier
and because I've been playing a lot I
would say that I've been fortunate
enough to be be able to play a lot not
everyone is caught up yet some people
are definitely getting Joe
Jake is pretty high
he's like 2200 something so might grab
Jake here in a second to try to do some
of the heroic more heroic thingies Rahl
there's Ralph's brother it should be
some more story once the expansions come
out they usually have a couple story
missions at night like
there here was the high-value target and
someone killed it
but we can still reap the benefits
here's another chest the guy okay so he
must be doing the same thing I am just
call this the necess
also we can check out there's like these
other maps that you get later on to
these treasure maps I haven't done any
of them from Kate so we can check that
out as well
I'm guessing should get some decent food
in a way I'm kind of capped now most of
the legendary engrams unless I can hear
lucky will roll - 65 - 65 rather and
most of the NPCs will only get you see
65 Benjamin Kindle I'm using the Sturm
and Drang experiment of a primary this
is a drain which is the sidearm
secondary that's a legendary and then
Sherman is a and I have the might a
launcher or something or though there's
a mighta that's a secondary if I had to
might a multi feel primary those kind of
combo together but I don't have a
primary
also just so you guys know from vendor
turn-ins I was actually able to get an
exotic this morning so be on the look
you know be on the lookout for that
hopes to get lucky obviously I've also
had some legendary engrams turning the
exotics which is not uncommon I just
didn't realize that you could actually
get exotics from the vendors to because
that exotic ended up to 21 first hearted
271 and it was a Sun shot which I don't
have yet because I took the graviton
Lance
yeah you could probably do the devil
Walker one solo game gamble you might be
able to do the glimmer one too it's just
that it's definitely easier with the
fireteam obviously and way more
efficient but yeah you're not wrong
saying
is there a quest for a multi-tool after
you do the mini tool because when I
looked at the EDC game's gambler
it's a classic cottage I didn't see it
I was doing it this morning maybe I just
missed it because it was on earth for
the Maite obviously and I don't like it
didn't didn't hang I didn't pick up
anything yet unless maybe there's
something on the tool tip so this is the
mighty boom mini tool SMD
am I missing something
yeah I don't know
people have guides on it is a four-step
bus ride I did go to the tower and talk
to banshee 44 gives me a new item okay
we'll check it out I thought I I thought
I did that already but I thought I'd
talk to Banshee already what
we can check that out thanks for the
tips guys
all right dear failsafe and Kate sign
ghost let's go talk to mr. Banshee real
quick oh yeah okay
I see it now I guess I didn't do that I
did do it this morning
right before I left for work so it's
probably there Thank You Kyle and games
gambler as well as goob
appreciate it I kind of figured it had
to be an exotic because that's how drain
and stem work so it makes sense that uh
might uh was another one of those things
another exotic that you can get and
there's also the and what's it called
the rat sidearm that one's a little bit
harder because I don't know if you could
like that was not so Louisville Sturm
and Drang are definitely solvable
gube the Mitel one is like 260 min
requirement I don't know if you have to
be 260 it's just like be mindful of that
where's dragons term we're like smaller
cooldown I guess Kyle Sirico are the
combo is worth it
I think it's I didn't interactions fun I
don't know like I probably wouldn't use
Sturm and Drang in a raid though
obviously I think Rat King exotic yeah
that wasn't a little tougher it's a
little longer because you need to you
need to ultimately do the nightfall
so obviously need a fireteam that can do
that all right here's the quest as they
had mentioned so you basically you know
gotta use let's see
you just got use a scout let me enemies
with precision and eliminate multiple
enemies probably before we're loading
like the other quest is my guess yep
alright so I have a pretty cool I got
lucky with this scout rifle a scout
rifle has explosive pretty much so we'll
just be using long and we'll go back to
necess because I have my map thingy
map packs essentially so we will go back
to Exodus black thank you for the tip we
will do this enhanced quest language I
did the first part already obviously so
now we're at Banshee so we just got to
do some stuff hopefully the rest of this
stuff is not as bad yeah as games
gambler mentioned rat pack does require
fireteam
yeah if you guys have any questions or
anything hit me up I will try to answer
them I haven't done too much with
modding but modding seems like it could
be pretty good you definitely don't want
a mod and before the raid Scout Eclipse
looking for some enemies kill obviously
any precision dots I also didn't realize
but a triple tap is back on as a perk
just cool you got asked out the other
day oh we got a legendary Engram that is
also like I said why you want to do
these treasure chest runs because you
can get engrams I don't know if you can
get exotic I mean I wouldn't be shocked
if you could
[Applause]
the as mentioned before here's the
high-value party
this is collision
oh hey guys yeah I have 9 9 plus I don't
think it has a cap
I spent a bunch just buying like maps
and whatnot so this is the vex one again
you could possibly that one's kind of
hard to sell though - I feel like let me
inspect that gear all right dude in a
second we're just working through some
exotic quests right now I'll do it dear
check what am I
no don't kill him on your pikes I know
you're trying to do the challenge but
I also have a challenge that I have to
accomplish
what is colliding in with the guys
[Applause]
also man the music is great as we can
that crosshair placement urged me that
was a suit Ewan Joseph Malley to unlock
patrols you need to finish campaign and
then there's a mission to make her to do
that quest you'll unlock the coals you
get one coin every time you finish one
so I just try to q1 up while I'm farming
the treasure chests and the high-value
target
through our public event her okay I
because I just wanna be
[Applause]
my Titan still looks ugly also there's a
lot of people kind of upset about
shading and wanting them to just be
permitted I think it's totally fine
and I say that because I don't know if
the people have gotten into like any
game in game but I have so many shaders
just from like playing the game and get
shaders from chests you get shaders for
frightened grams which you get every
time in the level sometimes get them
when you turn in and play
legendary engrams or like when you turn
in you know coins for trading in like
just get a bunch of haters I've used
like two mainly because I haven't really
even found here that I wanted to even
put shaders arms I only need six
you have one stop the plane
ghost and Guardian collection agency
that's us
well it's Josh's Josh I bring up the
point that not wanting to use them as a
problem yeah I guess from the standpoint
of like you shouldn't have to save them
but oh like if I have a really good
shader
I probably wait till I have a piece of
gear that I really want to put it on
because I mean I do play destiny fashion
that I used to call it fashion Souls and
Dark Souls so fast aney yes excellent
exercise your characters you transfer
over only in looks oh so like anything
else that I know doesn't necessarily
carry over I think someone can correct
me I forget it emblem how are we doing
on our quest we are doing mediocre
maybe explosives is bad for a headshots
though I might have to switch scout
rifles once we get this non reload one
specific for obvious reasons
the mighty quest anyway these necks
they're building something so to trigger
her rope on this one you want to cap
there's three of these pads that you
want to capture
there's an exploding guy
also I think you there's a you don't
want to let too many of the
someone has said that to people is a
good number to have any so once you
reach 100% there's another pad I think
there's two out of five
[Music]
I think if anything there's this one
so if you trigger the her oak obviously
to tell you that and what will happen is
a Hydra with a boss Hydra that wouldn't
have showed up otherwise
hold out
the funny thing is I'm rocking also
where right now - find Rey it's actually
[ __ ] white
it is a blue Gator
here
are not capable of digestion eat that
anyway
to feel organic instead of one halogen
TSA's pretty good
finally your failsafe and cake
we've got your stuff oh I think I know
which jock you're talking about goob
there is one exotic your Titan that
makes the hammer is like pretty good I
have the ones that help for boy Sentinel
it's pretty good
I'm trying to watch chat obviously
answer as many questions as I can Liz
how are you doing thanks for tuning in a
frequenter of the chats appreciate you
being here as well as many of you ever
since destiny came out I've probably
been sleeping like four or five hours a
day it's actually pretty tough playing
an activity last night
[Applause]
[Music]
nice job partner
hello fire heart's a high-value target
doctor funder but he's probably too far
away
primary precision shot probably gotta
ditch this guy when we need precision
y'all down with story or any we like
the S&P is awesome yeah it's pretty good
easily stable high fire rate high reward
rate
yes ah no coin it's a bad chest what do
you think of the cold heart I think it's
pretty decent I only used it right after
a campaign because if you pre-ordered
that's when you get it I think it's a
it's it's a really good weapon for when
I want to be lazy because I just hold
down the trigger it's because it's a
beam weapon for those that didn't know
cool sir dos de Silva I'm glad that
you're enjoying exactly what you pay for
would irlo have higher-level patrols and
law sectors potentially I honestly
haven't gone to IO or Titan that much I
need to go to Titan to do the there's
like a hive public event that I've never
done I know have you guys done a lot
in fire
there's a chest over here
you got all the gold reagent test yet I
didn't I just if I found it I found it
one of those things where if I go back
after the fact and find them all I've
gotten some though how many are there
per parent planet Bob would you like old
school destiny or it's like five
you've only found one I found
I think if you just do like lost sectors
and like quests you'll actually run into
some just like on
or they're doing it on purpose which is
fine
Oh where's bro go house is destiny to
our overwatch I mean kind of different
game obviously which is trials but it's
more like wow arena 3 b3 style whereas
overwatch is like it for the most part
sans like art is a game objective based
gaming I mean there are objectives
obviously in Destiny's PvP too but you
know what I mean there's more defined
classes even though there's three
classes in this game Keeler paint see
just have more shaders
very good I enjoyed it better than
Justin one
[Applause]
and then the other ones more rescued me
I believe right
I mean how all right so we just need
five more precision kills make sure
looks like a Call of Duty sniper we're
doing this
Jesus Garcia lawbreakers you like it
more people I ended up finding it more
enjoyable than they thought they would
but I don't know a lot of people that
stuck to that game a little bit it mean
it had a lot of styles had something of
its own you chest do something you try
sometimes you have nothing yes they give
glimmer sometimes or nothing
there's that part of the question we'll
see how many tokens do we have hopefully
we have 20 do it okay we do so I was
pretty fast right like I started with I
think roughly four tokens and in the
span of 30 minutes or so counting me
flying around everywhere we've gained so
it sounds like you can farm maybe 20 or
so it seemed bad because that's gonna
net you usually two Legendary's from the
NPC's on the planets so failsafe is
obviously
hello captain Republican it's starting
oh and I already turns them in so I'm
pretty sure if max is at 265
oh this home it's pretty cool I don't
want that home oh maybe I don't it look
cooler in the icon so this is the stuff
she can give you sometimes you don't get
to like items that should give you a
legendary charts which is fine you can
get 5 to 6 because there's coming back
so you want that currency I want to say
sometimes you get lucky and it could be
higher than 265 but for the most part
they've been to success I've got 4
things there
I've got a to weapons a shader
only to the postmaster because I was
fine
can you talk to banshee the question I
think we'll go out there real quick and
do this public events and then we shall
carry on seeming it's started
these necks they're building something
here let me help you out yes he did the
good thing where you know you have boys
calm but sometimes I just got to jump
around make it known hey I don't think
we need like
yeah the t65 seems like a soft cap goof
but I was able to get some higher level
stuff I will say - I want to say we'll
find out once we try to finish this
might of us but dude I finished my stern
quest and it gave me a 280 stir
we'll see if we can still do heroic with
three inspirations already gone it's
weird
I think we already blew it is why it
doesn't have it's not building more of
the pads
oh you know what screw it we are gonna
just go to Nanjing we got a we got our
coin from that chest which is as good as
it was potentially gonna get I was gonna
say maybe we could hopefully get an
exotic but not just what's the point in
having fancy armor and a ship the
majority of your time is spent in
first-person I mean because I can see it
when I go to my inventory people can see
me when I'm in a social space if I do a
dance or anything you can see it oh I
don't have some blues that are 261
that's interesting I thought maybe blues
soft capped at 260 but that doesn't seem
to be the case
obviously yep so she gave me a 265 and
then I'm not sure what the other one was
because I don't have it yet I needed
even though these are 260 I'm probably
not to start breaking some of this stuff
down yeah I don't need this many XP
chests it's kind of
yeah you could also as a king gene said
you can also when you're using a sword
be in third person Here I am in third
person it doesn't matter
checking now and 265 so nothing crazy
there fortunately your boy banshee here
hopefully the next part isn't too hard
hopefully it's just like going to a
mission and finish it good start
needs more details though lots of scouts
run on lighter principles crack them
open dismantle five valuable Scouts Oh
No
does that count as blue or do I have to
actually do Purple's fudge
I might have blue Scouts in my thing
here let's find out
note on that 265 soft cat that's the
night fall level is it I thought the
night fall was recommended 240
Boswell's hand cannons all right we got
one Scout in there so grab that real
quick
there anymore scouts know all right
let's see if this counts towards it does
okay so we only need a dismantle blues
the problem is I don't have any other
yeah I did don't worry Bob I got you but
thank you for having my back um I don't
know if I have
oh sweet we got another one here and
another one there okay so we got we got
three I could technically dismantle this
guy oh wait not that guy yeah it sucks
as an energy level
I play mostly for PvE but I do dabble in
the crucible iron banner and sometimes
I'll do trials obviously all right so
here's our predicament it's definitely
not blowing up that 265 Scout right now
because I might need it for an infusion
of water later
so my problem is I need two more blue
Scouts
maybe we'll get a purple have two
engrams alright so again 265 soft cap
and no chest and a heavy and 265 so
there you go there's other things I can
train en garde like I have my powerful
gear that I could turn in I win I
probably wouldn't blow those up we can
also try to try to gun our way there
give me a scout that is mask out the
sniper dang it yeah level of gaming Oh
salty because PC doesn't come out for a
month
feels bad for sure but I think they have
some optimising still left to do is why
alright I guess we got to go back to
necess and try to farm us ourselves to
more Scouts how likely that's going to
be but
I guess that's where we're going unless
somebody knows a faster way to get Scout
rifles to blow up if if we get one more
blue I'll just blow up a purple call it
a day just to get might uh well we'll
probably have to do a mission to get my
toes my guess what's up ooh gee good to
see you
remember guys if you guys didn't know
live every day at 11 so you're not
already subscribed or following guy
should do that so that you get
notifications when we go alive yeah we
got a series called Destiny's children
coming soon UK and us productions UK is
gonna handle Friday's Lucita more and
Dave are gonna play together as a
fireteam and then here on Tuesdays we're
gonna do a live stream every Tuesday for
the next like you know one and a half
months or more it would be kind of a
rotating cast of me John Luke and Rob so
make sure to check that out stay tuned
for that that's gonna be awesome
you know means any reason to play more
destiny is all good with me one more
blue cow oh he just dropped the blue but
it was Jesus with the perv
let's go maybe we can farm enough you
think a [ __ ] might be worth more than
that's actually not a terrible idea
but it feels really bad to blow up with
265 you look like one of our local union
reps I hate you that was evolutis I'm
sorry that I remind you of your
Ponyville it wasn't the union I thought
the union usually tries to like protect
their people and like you guys I'm sorry
that I look like that guy you know he's
not doing his job I hope that you enjoy
the stream regardless of that and maybe
by the end of the stream if you stick
around maybe your opinion will change
maybe a home but you know one can hope
and try great JM 76 blow it up anyways
you're gonna grind yeah but I don't have
that many 265 primaries right now JM so
I need I need that fodder
need that water but you are probably
right though you are probably right but
I only have one purple so if if one
purple is not enough but I guess
hypothetically if that one purple turned
into a mite uh then I guess is worth it
because the mighta could be to eight I
need that might up i do do i do -
especially for pvp my toe is are like go
- yeah I'm 76 one of my fire team squad
members Mahal er actually the funny
thing is if you look at a lot of my
memories I would say JM and VIN would
wash south or are probably in at least
66% 75% of those
can't say how many times I missed a
Ledge by to fix it yeah I feel you level
up gaming the funny thing is like
sometimes you think oh I'm probably on a
mantle right got it
there's no way I'm not gonna mantle here
and then it doesn't magical there's
certain things that you can't man so
long I guess I mean there's got to be
because obviously I'm missing some of
these gems but I thought you target is
nearby we have a general idea worried
that easy to the million one spot
surround this circle
happy sad and did I make this up I'm
like you guys he's not over here
weird up notes to make them
[Applause]
give me a boost
we're not even close on tokens huh oh no
we have 23 all right maybe we can just
go get a purple scout from failsafe
let's pray for that
so is this game good it says great
Bureau Hewitt I enjoyed a lot I think
it's fun it's an action shooter that
borrows RPG type elements it's got a
raid it's got dungeons so there's like
team-based stuff you get solo it if you
I would say that shooting mechanics are
still some of the best out there for me
personally that are out and available
right now hg h jg TV says yo yo what's
up man alright come on Scout me another
sniper oh it's got that one perk what
was it
oh it's outlaw I'm lon sniper and chest
that doesn't have a thingy but it looks
like it could be cooler look in the mind
yeah it kind of does look cooler
alright so that failed
[Music]
what's the word on matchmaking works for
stuff like raids my college trials
I believe no matchmaking for trials or
raid and I'm not sure about nightfall
I'm gonna assume that there isn't but I
can't yeah
but with the clan system the hope is
that the clan system helps alleviate
that and it'll let some solo players
hopefully team up with clan members to
do some of those events also when I
mentioned Destiny's children and live
streaming on Tuesdays GameSpot does have
a clan and you know there's probably
gonna be a couple streams where maybe on
Tuesdays on reset days maybe we try to
do a nightfall with some folks try to
help people out when we can
[Music]
going wild no guys
- try it easy
we have like
fifteen tokens so like five more
deferens
that's why it's called failsafe yes Matt
Marlo on points and accurate yo how do I
get my Sparrow damn dr. strange you got
to know how to get your spare all right
you don't even need a sparrow because
you can like travel time and [ __ ] right
okay so fun fact we do have a YouTube
video about how to get a sparrow but
I'll tell you how to get it anyways but
I think you should watch that YouTube
video if you have a time so the easiest
way to get a sparrow is campaign however
if you're feeding to try to get one
before you finish the campaign then
Janka actually got one in a crucible
match last night and he had not finished
the campaign yet so I think the earliest
way you could get a sparrow that I can
think of maybe outside I don't know if
you can get it out of a bright Engram
you might be able to free but the
fastest way
would be too
get lucky
according that
oh this guy could be scary yeah see he
takes you and like you like
that is not there yeah I don't know if
you guys noticed it but you did trigger
hard mode
what I did
Oh double blue scout that's what I'm
talking about that is what I'm talking
about and we finished the via the
question how much are the Patrol Oh talk
about timing
that was immaculate it must have been
streamers luck right streamers luck
gotta be streamers luck because of you
guys in the chat channeled your powers
Goku tit and you're like yeah here you
go oh yeah philanthropy is right you
cannot buy a Brighton Graham until level
20 so he is correct so I guess the only
way that we know of that has worked so
far for one person is crucible to get
the spare oh here we go
boom Shakalaka I really should have been
recording back that fight there what are
you grinding now to level up acid oops
you right
basically what I'm showing you that's
what I've done today it seems kind of
efficient I don't know if it's the best
route it's just what I discovered on my
own I was like hey I'm on necess I
happen to pop them and I'm like oh
there's actually a lot of treasure
chests in this very small circle and so
I do patrols while I'm farming the
chests while I'm farming that interlace
entered data lace also killing that
high-value target that spawns every now
and then that captain this one's it like
they got one kind of like spot near the
other fallen then doing the public
events when they're there trying to make
them heroic because heroic will give you
more loot so that's what I've been doing
I want to say it's more efficient than
strikes but I'm not sure I haven't
actually fired teamed up and just like
ran a bunch of strikes so hard to say if
that's the way to go you do you can't
buy these medallions from tests you do
get one from beating the game and I
think it increases XP gains and loot for
your fire team from public events
strikes and crucible I've never popped
that but I'm guessing if you want to go
on this huge farm run with a fire team
you know catcher rock stars energy and
what not for four hours straight I think
that might be the way to go I did not
see the strike bonus Bob but again I
haven't run strikes too much so it's
hard for me to say that would work all
right we need to crush the rest and boom
and we got the quest before I gotta go
do a mission get that mitre the fall
will kill you
almost got it still need huh kind of a
strange one still need some more data
great all right what's what are we doing
what are we doing banshee
airborne alright cuz I have the map
there I'm sorry if you guys are sick
with misses actually you know what we'll
go eat easy we'll go eat easy because I
think you can kind of do the same run
here at the front I'm not positive I
haven't done it enough but there you go
you clear out all the missions on each
planet there should be three exotic
alloys I have not the third one as I
mentioned the Rat King which is another
exotic that you can get needs a fireteam
so I've I'm just doing the ones that you
can solo as the rest of game SWAT and
some of my friends catch up again I did
kind of have a little bit of a head
start also I work at GameSpot again
blessed and fortunate to be here to do
what I'm doing so that has also allowed
me to kind of kind of get a little bit
farther but I will say I've I've also
put in the time
like last night PSN was having huge
issues and I actually wasn't able to
login I only slept like five hours
woke up early did that farming grind run
that you guys were watching there but
I'm kind of I'm kind of at the I'm kind
of at the end of what I'm able to do
outside of the nightfall
and maybe the treasure map stuff might
have higher level I don't know we're
gonna we should do one it's in the EDC
so I guess it's good that it came here
those you can also buy from pay I think
you can only buy X amount per week 100%
sure on that I'd have to try doing one I
don't know if this is worse or doing a
missions worse but I feel like they're
gonna make me do a mission after this -
I just I can sense it in my bones
but you know what would be the best for
this warlock because they can do that
hover [ __ ] in the air whereas my Titan
just got to do like one killing time
you know what I should be going in to
begin
I'll value patience I can't stress that
enough I you know what I I don't know if
you guys have been doing this stuff but
I'm kind of curious what you guys as
thoughts are on regarding these like
dust shards and that interlace data I
picked them up right but I feel like the
benefits or the gains are not very high
so I don't even know if they're worth
picking up it's so little executable so
it makes me like not want to do them
is so silly did we find a little
here Deborah
all right back to airborne SMD kills
have you done any meditations be honest
I'm not even sure what that is how many
do we yeah like 20 maybe oh we're doing
good 29 all right all right I do not
lose faith then
[Applause]
a green ammo
yes I am trying to get my tie that's why
I'm doing Michael V that is why I'm
jumping it's part of a quest line I
think it's silly but whatever all for
the Maite
yeah okay I can do this
this reminds me of a p90 yeah it's a
pretty good Jam forget what the bonuses
with my tie but might be worth just
having because never uses don't just
never use a secondary and just go pull
my toe
no green mo to be seen as might've just
not have the first anymore you have that
boat equipped you faster might not be
that bad though
[Music]
I assume since our name I did not see
since being so if they're like trying to
teach you to like call duty destiny okay
what you should do here is you should
Oh Ingram so I've gotten lucky I will
say I've gotten to exotics from
legendary engrams which is obviously
possible
so hopefully you guys
[Applause]
yeah we did it back to banj here we go
I need that JM orangey today and
tomorrow you got him in I'll try to help
you out tonight Jam I should be should
be pretty free
so Michael V just did my first strike
I'm glad I waited till I was fully
legendary to do it [ __ ] was epic yeah
I've only done three out of the five I
think it's six for ps4 five for Xbox but
I've done three of the six strikes on
ps4 and so far they've been pretty good
like that
that one with like the laser beams and
kind of like a atheon guy at the end
that one was pretty intense just kind of
liking the level design the puzzle the
even though they're kind of puzzle light
I'm enjoying them quite a bit
yeah level up the story's about eight to
ten hours why you falling asleep
Anastasio khan toasted khan stereos
sorry i butchered your name wake up the
morning o this also has outlaws that's
good blow up some boots
making sure it's not of course oh we got
it
and it's 283 get hype ok so thank you
one for the tip guys appreciate it in
YouTube chat second pro tip I guess is
wait wait as long as you can on turning
in or doing these quests for Drang or
sorry force term and for Maite because
obviously the higher you are the higher
this reward will be so I'm getting a 283
might a multi-tool from this by waiting
by being higher light level or pirate
leveled boom we got that mighta that
mighta life let's go that is
that is that feels good it's good to
have an old friend back weapon boost
movement speed as it was before
corkscrew rifling slightly increases
range and stability slightly increases
handling high caliber rounds miter radar
that which is awesome Raiders always up
and handle eight stock so there you go
there's my to give you some war I'm not
gonna read it all but that is awesome
pretty sweet stuff there alright and we
got the miter to go with it so sweat for
grants speed benefits when white a
multi-tool is equipment I guess when
you're using the minigun you also get to
run faster so it's not imperative that
you have this on to be honest because
it's not like this synergizes because of
this this just in here does is because
of your might announce your tool so you
could have whatever secondary you want
I don't know I think it's worth
GUP but let's see it use kind of sad I
don't have my Arctic shader anymore the
ornament from destiny one I had blow I
had coke covert ops version and also art
you know what I'm kind of curious I
think we're at a point where we can turn
in these powerful gear quests I was
waiting to turn these into because it
was rumored or like I don't know who's
rumored or if it's actual fact but
apparently if you guys look at your
milestones
I think there's weekly challenges right
there that give you powerful gear now
I've finished one for Kade so we're
gonna see if that's true or not and see
if it's a higher than 265 legendary if
it's not that kind of sucks but I think
since it's a weekly challenge kind of
thing it should be higher than 265 that
is the hope I mean I'm not gonna be
higher than I am right now unless you
never let him cheat so oh it's a 275 so
it's known as a luminous planetary
Engram so it's a instead of 265 it's at
least a min 275
all right let's hope for the best I
guess
I'm hoping that it's two items - that'd
be nice - oh we got an exotic out of it
hey
Yahtzee bazinga that is sweet we will
take everything we can for more like 1
282 marchers and now 270 power feels
good it feels good
we are nightfall ready the only thing I
can improve upon is I think I could get
a 265 glove which would help a lot and
then a 265 mark other than that we're
over 265 or every other stroke so I'm
just making awards because it felt so
good I don't think do marchers are that
great but you know sure
[Music]
this one's math to the peacekeepers so
but we'll rock those for now because
that's what we got obviously and we're
not gonna get higher than 280 so if once
we finish the knife fault and I fall
should give obviously good rewards
potential for exotic I would assume like
the old knife Falls and then we can also
get a 275 from Zabala it looks like you
get two items at least two Legendary's
that are 275 with the chance for an
exotic obviously which is huge so yeah
it's been a pretty good day
not much left to show at least today
we're gonna obviously be back tomorrow
streamers and destiny as well check out
what we got for the brightening room got
a ghost and of course more shaders and
another transmat effect for a ship I'm
not really huge on my scale in my ship
but it's the only one I've gotten since
having the day one ship essentially the
title dawn we can change the transmat
effects but once we apply it that is
gone I guess I know we have to goes to
blue I really want to use this but I
don't want to on the ship I don't think
no word from Fenchurch today he must
have found something interesting
another minor thing look I even get
auras on lot have you guys unlocked
auras is that something that's hard to
do auras
weekly so anything that says powerful
gear you want to save so weekly was for
cage and also from Zavala those are the
two that I've gotten I haven't done the
night ball yet obviously so I can't get
that other powerful piece of gear yet
but once we get the knife all done when
I can get a group fireteam group ready
we'll go ahead and do that obviously see
this guys rocking the shaders all right
he's doing a good job of doing fashion
fashion and he he's like mostly matching
he looks better than I do to be honest I
look like cuz I got this I got a shitty
looking retro stuff the retro stuff
looks just awful you just look like a
worn down tight man you don't want to
look like a cool futuristic one
this has to be ornaments right oh I can
watch shader on it that's right alright
so I could match where's my uh there's
that one shader oh I got more shaders
yeah I've been using Avalon teal what
does that look like
yeah yeah we'll do that cuz I don't want
that that neon green so we're sort of
getting there our look is soar to get a
I put a shader on what did that not
apply I totally put a shader on this
thing right no I didn't I lied why did
that go through there we go boom
we're mostly mostly there are how many
dumb work Helmut definitely
all right well I'm gonna wrap this
stream up so we can I can go help start
getting on some of those guides thank
you guys all for your help again thank
you guys all for tuning in we will be
back tomorrow at 11:00 of course I think
we're gonna do destiny again just
because trials is out tomorrow and xur
is also available he'll be out at 2:00
a.m. Pacific he's gonna be on one of the
four planets which is new and
interesting I'm kind of curious if he's
wandering I doubt it so we'll see if
he's in just like the social hub of like
where the NPCs are or if you somewhere
like way crazier hard to say looking
forward to seeing the Destiny's version
of Santa shows up once a week but thank
you guys all for tuning in and uh his
trials next week
oh maybe Charles is next week with the
raid my bad trials is not tomorrow
you're right Bob Jones thank you for the
correction so that might change what we
do tomorrow but we'll probably check out
sir maybe we'll do some crucible or
something maybe we'll do strikes I don't
know hard to say but uh tune in tomorrow
11:00 we'll be back thank you guys all
for watching hope you guys had a good
time I know I did later
[Music]
[Music]